[Applause]
thank you so much well thank you it's
nice to be in a place with no riots and
I only saw about a dozen police officers
not 400 so that was exciting and I did
promise the police officers who are not
here on overtime that we would try to
keep to the time limits that they can go
home but I wanted to start by I was just
gonna launch right into the speech first
of course I want to thank you America's
foundation for sponsoring the event and
the local chapter of yeah for doing such
a wonderful job getting the word out and
if there are people on the other side
people of the left if you could raise
your hands I'd like to give you a round
of applause for coming because I
appreciate it well thank you
[Music]
now I want to do that because then I'm
gonna mock you but it's just but that's
just the way this goes it's part of the
that's part of the story so in that in
the in the name of that I'm just gonna
launch in my speech but I was handed
this pamphlet from from the young
democratic socialists all about how
capitalism really hasn't done anything
for us I mean I can I can tell you one
thing capitalism would do for you get
you some better graphic design
I do like some of the some of the facts
that are in here things like have you
ever wondered why there are five times
as many empty houses as there are
homeless people in the United States
well I've never really wondered that
because the people who are building
those empty houses are hoping to sell
those empty houses presumably if you
want to see places that are full that
are prison camps in North Korea and as
far as the homeless problem in the
United States it would be remiss not to
acknowledge that homelessness is highly
linked unfortunately to mental illness
so if we're going to talk about the
homeless problem it has far less to do
with the availability of housing and far
more to do with the fact that we have
not done enough in terms of caring for
the mentally ill it says why we wait
have you ever wondered why we waste over
a hundred and thirty three billion
pounds of food thirty to forty percent
of the food supply each year when people
still go hungry I actually had not
wondered that ever since I was five and
my mother said to me if you don't eat
that food someone in China will starve
and I figured that is not true if I
donate this food then that person in
China will have just as little food as
that person would have had otherwise
unless you can freeze drive this sucker
and send it over there and speaking of
food shortages has has anybody ever
wondered why it is that everyone in
Ukraine from like 1932-1933 had none of
it it has more to do with socialism than
with capitalism have you ever wondered
why just eight men owned as much wealth
as the other half of the world I haven't
really wondered that either since
capitalism has raised literally half the
globe from abject poverty since 1980 and
it turns out that those people who are
enormous ly wealthy have generated more
wealth for more people than have
virtually anyone else on the planet and
says what have I ever wondered why
college students are saddled with the
burdens of death so they can become
qualified I have and I also wonder why
you would spend money to come to a
college so you could learn nothing and
put out garbage like this that seems
like a waste of money
my favorite part of this pamphlet is
actually this this particular page right
here it says did you know and then
there's a picture of Albert Einstein in
a picture of Martin Luther King and a
picture of Helen Keller and says did you
know Einstein Martin Luther King jr. and
Helen Keller or socialist I figure they
did that because it wouldn't look as
good if it said did you know that Stalin
Mao Hugo Chavez and Castro were
socialists
it turns out that being a socialist in
America which has not embraced socialism
is a really lucrative a nice thing you
can become famous you can become rich
you can become well-known without ever
having to implement any of your ideas
that's convenient okay so now to the
actual speech so I want to do something
a little bit different tonight normally
I launch right into my normal tie a
tribe about about white privilege and
why it's nonsense and why people are not
victims but I want to talk about a
little bit of deeper philosophy today
I don't do something different so I
figure a lot of people in the room have
probably seen some of my other speeches
and so I want to do this is the first
run is a test run for for a new sort of
speech that I want to give tonight and
that is I want to talk about some of the
deeper philosophical roots of why we are
so split in the country one of the
things that has really become clear to
me personally is just how split we are I
mean when I have to go on a campus and
people have to spend six hundred
thousand dollars just so that I can talk
when we are having knock-down drag-out
fights over really nothing's in terms of
politics I mean the differentiation
between the Republican Party on Jaca and
the Democratic Party on Jack are pretty
much nil at this point and yet we are
having knock-down drag-out fights over
this and a lot of it has to do with the
the idea that we just ascribe bad
motives to one another so I want to get
a couple of things out of the way so
that we can talk about what's really
separating us can you have a quick show
of hands who here in this room who's
conservative thinks black people are
genetically inferior okay for those who
can't see on camera that is zero hands
right who here in this room who is
conservative feels that women are
inherently less qualified for job
positions
hey no hands go up who here in this room
believes that poor people are inherently
evil and deserve to suffer no hands okay
so now we can get all of those motives
out of the way because those motives
have now been ascribed repeatedly to
everybody on my side of the aisle right
these motives are constantly ascribed to
people on my side of the aisle racist
sexist bigoted homophobes gay gay people
and we hate black people and we hate
women and none of this is true so here's
the question why are we having these
battles where we ascribe these sort of
motives to one another and I think that
it goes to something a little bit deeper
than just your everyday politics I think
something really devastating has
happened to the West and it's come to
America over the last few decades but in
the West over the last couple of hundred
years and that is we no longer
in this country and the West at large
have a common vision of meaning we no
longer believe in share a society
because we don't share a vision of what
the country ought to be so let's go back
to serious basics what exactly is the
meaning of life okay what is the meaning
of being a person what's the meaning of
existing in a society together what are
we striving for what are we trying to do
together because if we can't agree on
that it's gonna be very difficult for us
to agree on things as simple as
ascribing decent motives to one another
so let's start at the root okay not the
Howard Zinn version of America where all
the founders were evil trying to protect
their own private property that's a
historical and untrue okay let's start
from the actual root of what America is
all about and that of course is the idea
of the pursuit of happiness but
Jefferson and Thomas Jefferson and the
rest of the founders when they said
pursuit of happiness they didn't just
mean the right to get your rocks off and
smoke pot in your dorm room
yeah but the amount was something
actually rather specific they thought
about happiness and the pursuit of
happiness in terms of an Aristotelian
notion of fulfilling your goal in life
which is the pursuit of people who were
twisted this is what makes you happy
what makes you happier is the pursuit of
virtue revenue no three societies that
you can using their free will pursue
becoming a better person in accordance
with her mission a mission that we can
figure out simply by thinking about in
reqtest the Aristotelian natural rights
notion and animated so many of the
barriers American society less than
general in America the apotheosis to
this is based on two fundamental roots
Athens in Jerusalem today on Christian
value system and the Athenian notion
that right reason is what is going to
endow you with a a life of happiness and
meaning today of Christian values teach
us we have individual me right it
teaches us we have a are made in the
image of God they're all individually
valuable this is what equality means in
the conservative perspective the family
expected nothing rough people able not
that we all are equally hate both with
certain activities because I'm never
going to play football and never to me
at all like it's not going to happen
right but we that does not mean that I'm
not able to make Amanda and God sense in
fact
according to according to the Bible they
keep keep perdition of all of Western
thought lies in Genesis 1:26 the idea
that we each of us and every one of us
is made in the image of God that is
that's the first fundamental basis of
Western civilization and the second
fundamental basis of Western
civilization comes from the appellant's
it comes from grip god which suggests
that the best way to act virtuously is
to use reason and instead of feeling
that one of our jobs is to help train
our feelings to move in accordance with
our reason but if we're not reasoning if
we're not losing a lot we're not losing
fact then we're doing something wrong
we're not emerald succulent babies have
given to you as an adult human being you
have raised the feather to believe both
of mistakes they believe that happiness
lay and believe in both of these things
that you have a child on this earth and
that is to the devastation system follow
God by acknowledging the value of other
human beings and in the Athenian value
system by becoming a better person
through introspection and self-training
right family both of these things her to
Washington summed it up well except the
consideration that human happiness and
moral duty are inseparably connected
will always continue to prompt me to
promote the progress of the learner by
him committing the practice of leather
so it wasn't just at the founder share
the goal they also had a plan
they're basically four things that you
need in order to pursue happiness anyway
there's blood that's all to pursue
happiness and felt that all the human
beings you pursue happiness
the first one is individual permits we
all have to have a purpose below but if
you don't have a purpose you're gonna be
depressed we're gonna live it's that way
individual purpose is heavily connected
with living second in the control
capacity you have to believe that you
are in control of your destiny non
society genetics you you as a free
independent human being have the
capacity to make your life better
third you have that communal purpose
fragment work we're social beings we
exist with each other and we have to
feel that we're all part of the same
fight you have to feel like we're all
waiting together for something
finally you need communal capacity you
have to feel like the community is
actually moving us towards this communal
purpose so as I say we need an
individual purpose because without
individual purpose life becomes
meaningless
this is what again Aristotle and the
Bible provide is this notion that you as
an individual living on a desert island
you still have a purpose your purpose is
to reason your purpose is to worship God
your purpose is to become a better human
being right you have an individual
purpose apart from what other people
want of you now in our society we've
sort of tossed this out in favor of this
idea that individualism is about pursuit
of pleasure whatever floats your boat
whatever I define Liberty as whatever I
want to do and you can do all those
things that's fine but the idea that
entire society can be based on the
pursuit of individual pleasure is just
not true which is of course why John
Adams suggested that a constitutional
Free Republic could only be based on a
moral and religious people and no one
else okay but it's not enough to just
have purpose we have to believe that we
can achieve that purpose we have to
believe that we can achieve our goals if
we don't believe that we tend to give up
we get depressed we said we sit the
battle's out unfortunately on this one -
there's been a big fight against the
notion of individual capacity I don't
discuss that in a second right in order
for you to believe that you have
capacity you have to believe that you
have the capacity for reason you have to
believe certain basic assumptions that
you never think about like you are an
actual individual human being not just a
cluster of cells that changes every day
you're an individual human being who
makes decisions on a day to day basis
and then you're responsible for those
decisions using something called reason
right these are all assumptions as we'll
see in a second that have been ripped
out from under build the country
together so we can promote those values
among ourselves and to other people and
finally we need communal capacity we
need a balance between a community that
believes in values and a community that
allows us to exercise our free will to
pursue those values right we don't want
a theocracy where the government just
forces you to do things but we also
don't want in an arc in anarchic system
where we have no social safety net
whatsoever in terms of our support for
one another and anything can be taken
away from you at any time
okay so to recap very briefly individual
purpose individual capacity communal
purpose communal capacity these are the
four things you need to pursue happiness
and the left has torn each one of these
four things down I don't just mean the
American left I mean the Marxist left
you know the folks who promote
democratic socialism have their roots in
Marx Marx opposed each of these notions
at least in the in the founding version
of them it goes back even further than
Marx if you go to people like David Hume
they're philosophers for 400 years who
have been claiming that aspects of each
of these four things have to be taken
away first individual purpose so the
left believes there is no individual
purpose that is universal to all of us
we don't all have the same individual
purpose right as human beings we don't
have a better version of human beings
we're trying to turn into there is no
Aristotelian pursuit of virtue
there's just whatever I want today my
individual purpose is whatever I want
today which basically leaves us alone in
a godless universe striving to lash out
and make a way for ourselves right it's
it's it's sort of jean-paul Sartre
existentialism problem is again you
build a society based on this we tend to
think that my individual purpose is the
best individual purpose but your
individual purpose sucks and so if
they're in conflict it's not because we
don't share an individual purpose it's
because mine is right and yours is wrong
even if I can't argue why mine is right
or yours is wrong second individual
capacity this one the left has really
taken on the idea that you are capable
of making decisions every single aspect
of this one has been taken on by the
left first of all the idea of scientific
materialism rips away it rips away at
the very heart of identity you as an
individual human being capable of acting
in the world if you're a scientific
determinist then you tend to believe
that all human activity is traceable to
neurons firing in your brain or the
environment around you that's what human
beings are we're just a set of chemicals
and neurons and biological functions
that's all we are well then you can't
act in the universe right how are you
supposed to better yourself it's an
oxymoron you can't better yourself right
you're not even you you're just a thing
you're a ball of meat floating around in
this universe you're not
important you have no inherent value
there's no such thing as reason by the
way in this in this version reason is
just a social construct reason is just
one set of neurons firing as opposed to
a different set of neurons firing okay
so this is a neuron fires in your
prefrontal cortex
well what's why is that any better than
the neurons firing in your amygdala what
difference does it make you do not have
capacity to move and then the Marxist
left takes it even further
they say that society defines you I mean
it says so right here in this in this
special pamphlet that I saw actually it
says right here in the special pamphlet
when it says common myths about
socialism truth social circumstances
effect behaviors right and the Marxists
thought is that human beings become
better because of the social
circumstances in which they find
themselves that if we just change
society around you there's no such thing
as human nature you are just going to be
the aftereffect of whatever nature and
society create around you this is not
likely to give you a feeling of Verve
about getting up in the morning right
you're basically getting kicked around
like a soccer ball by the universe enjoy
right you are now Spinoza's rock
floating through space with the
self-awareness to understand that you
weren't actually you didn't throw
yourself that you've just been thrown
and you're kind of floating around and
that's it okay fine third communal
communal communal purpose so the left
has substituted new communal purposes
for the old communal purposes so the old
communal purpose was the idea that we as
a society are going to make it easier
for you to be virtuous by granting you
the freedom to act in accordance with
virtue but also setting certain social
standards outside of governments that in
cocaine virtue and individual citizens
right this is the John Adams vision of
what the community is supposed to do not
theocracy and not anarchy but a society
that provides you the freedom to explore
your own virtue
well while creating systems outside of
government that help promote that right
that was the idea of the communal
purpose and doing that as much as we can
all over the world depending on the cost
right the left has substituted utopian
communal purpose because Aristotle in
the Bible no longer exists in this world
so instead of that what we get are these
various utopian schemes
raiga communism which is redistribute
all the property and everything will be
all better you as an individual no
longer matter because why should you I
mean again you're a ball of meat so what
difference does it make if you have to
break a few eggs to make an omelet well
utopia is on the way social institutions
that exist
on the insistent exists based on these
old values they have to be torn out root
and branch to make way for something new
and the left in its desire to create
these new communities has created this
intersectional hierarchy where we are no
longer members of a common community
with a common set of values now we can
be identified by our biological features
which is very exciting right you're no
longer a human being who's an individual
with thoughts and purposes you are now a
member of a community and only a member
of a community you're a member of the
black community remember the white
community remember of the Asian
community and what's more because the
society is unfair we can actually
determine how valuable your perspective
is based on which membership in which
group you belong and this is
intersectionality so as I've said before
there's a hierarchy so if you're LGBTQ
or it's very top your opinion matters
most because you've been most victimized
then comes black people then comes to
spanning people then comes Asians then
comes women then comes Hispanics then
comes Jews then comes white people right
and then and we can determine how
valuable your opinion is based on your
biological membership or depending on
whether what we're talking about
non-biological membership in a
particular group none of this is likely
to lead you to any purpose that is worth
following
and finally communal capacity so again
the web doesn't believe that we ought to
have a community that exists with both
social standards and freedom instead
what we have to have is a community that
forces you to do things we need a
community that forces you to do things
after all it's the only thing we have
left in common as Barack Obama said in
2012 government's is the only thing we
have left in common so this is what the
left wants in the end a world in which
individual purpose is not connected to
virtue in which judeo-christian Western
commit Western communal purpose is
replaced with classism and tribalism in
which we are told that on our own we are
nothing and in which we are told that
our only purpose is to be a cog in the
machine of some communal purpose and
this is what we're fighting and this is
what we have to keep in mind because
America was built unprecedented great
each other so angry at each other is
because there is a purpose shaped hole
in our hearts that we are filling with
anger right we all had purpose
Philby web purpose people who thought
they were better in the world and
bettering themselves focus mostly on
bettering themselves with their family
in their status the world and that's
been taken away from us we don't have
the capacity for that we don't have the
purpose we don't have a country that's
built for that we have a mean nasty
country that's built on mean nasty
people with mean nasty purposes and we
are still motivated to do something so
that motivation is now anger and so we
hate each other
we're enraged with each other and it
doesn't matter of what the other person
is saying is evidence-based we don't
even look that's in common all that we
hold in common is our anger because we
believe that the other person is trying
to hurt us because the anger gives us
meaning anger is not what gives us
meaning purpose again is what gives us
meaning purpose is what creates the
pursuit of happiness that we need it is
that purpose that we can restore it's
not difficult all it takes is a little
bit of self-education a little bit of
adherence to a few old-fashioned values
not all of them some of them right a
belief in yourself that you have the
capacity succeed I believe in your own
reason I believe in your own abilities
in your own hard work a belief in the
American system that creates the freedom
for you to rise up in the world and not
to be buried under all of these myths
about your value lessness and if we
follow back the path to to our roots if
we follow the path back to why would we
matter as individuals and why America
was built the way that it was we can
have that freedom again and we can love
each other once again as opposed to
hating each other and being at each
other's throats
thanks so much happy to take questions
[Music]
so
now for the fun part as always those who
disagree get to go first
if you raise your hand you go up to the
front of the line at this time we will
be taking questions if you have a
question please file through the back of
the house down here we'll hand you the
mic if you have a question please follow
through the back of the house and we'll
hand you the mic
yeah
um hello Ben Shapiro hello how are you
very well sir
what I was gonna ask was as many of us
have noticed feminism has destroyed
gender relations between men and women
for decades for example me I can go up
to a woman somewhere on Berkeley and
tell her she's beautiful without being
accused of sexual harassment what would
it take for us to repair that damage if
possible at all so I mean I think that
it's important to distinguish between
different waves of feminism so first
wave feminism which is basically the
idea that women should be able to get
whatever jobs they're qualified for and
women should be able to vote first wait
feminism is something with which I fully
agree second and third wave feminism
when we get into this idea that women
are oppressed members of society and
that all men any time a man complements
a woman this is a form of societal
oppression and that all gender
differences are social constructs now
this is nonsense so I mean I think that
you know I'm not big on dating advice as
a general rule mainly because mainly
because I was fixed up by my sister with
my wife and she was my and my wife was
my first serious girlfriend so I can't
speak as somebody who who has long and
fruitful experience in these matters but
but what I will say is that I think that
our society has failed to draw any clear
scanners with regards to what behavior
is considered appropriate and what
behavior is not considered appropriate
so there are things that we all agree
right sexual assault bad right rapists
go to jail be castrated be killed right
we all we all basically have this idea
but I mean all that I can say is if a
woman is so deeply offended by you
saying you know I think you're beautiful
then she's probably not somebody you
want to be dating if if she and if the
the real danger is that we are now
creating a system where complaints could
be filed against somebody for saying
something as innocuous as I think that
you're beautiful which again one of the
problems with standards like this is
it's sort of like justice Potter Stewart
on pornography I'll know it's bad when I
see it right I'll know it when I see it
so Michael Moore is saying exact same
words that Tom Cruise is saying it means
that Michael Moore is physically
repulsive so that's
the only point that I've ever played by
making is that we actually have to have
subset of social standards at least with
regard to how we enforce the standards
on campus that protects men but also
continues to protect that night and I
would urge you know women who are
concerned about these issues to speak
with medicine you can come up with some
sort of agreement on what constitutes
appropriate behavior and once it's not
like for me I have a pretty specific
rule which I had never touched a woman
without explicit permission you know
this is there's a lot to talk about in
workplace harassment that's pretty steep
rule but the same left that says that
might been disapproved for not going out
to dinner with women who are not his
wife
suggests that if you do Westerner with a
woman who's not your wife you may be
sexually harassed so they're there no
other standards
[Applause]
hi Ben thank you so much for Monday have
you ever seen do you know the purpose of
their ambience Dale yes okay so I'm a
student here at UT I was participating
in a debate in my religious studies in
the pop culture class about whether a
Handmaid's Tale committed become reality
in America most of the class parking
that it could happen I understand the
spirit I disagree with the argument and
think of the assumption that all white
Christian girls really want to enslave
women anemic honest insult to you come
in this country and the progress will be
advanced Paris nation additionally
there's your evidence where policy in
place that comes to the country moving
in this direction so I'm carrying its s
away her opinion is and weigh your
argument would be okay because the only
regimes on earth that look like to
Handmaid's Tale exist in radical Muslim
countries like Saudi Arabia or Pakistan
or Afghanistan as far as the idea that
America is standing right on the verge
of this this is such sheer and
unadulterated crap I hesitate to even
respond to it except to note the
majority of college grads are women the
majority of graduate school grads are
women in one in one hundred and eight of
America's biggest cities women make more
it's sorry in America's forty seven of
America's top fifty cities
women make more than men do if they are
equally qualified coming out of college
and are not and don't have kids and work
the same number of hours women are
earning more than men women are earning
more college degrees than men women are
doing just fine in American society and
the idea that Oh
first of all I've always known bizarre
this notion that men are looking to
chain up women's that we can use them
for or to make babies that's that's
always been a weird one for me I mean
last I checked I mean anytime you see a
pinup calendar it's not a bunch of
pregnant ladies like well that that's
actually not our bag like
I think that if you're going to talk
about the evil impulses of men well you
might suggest that men want to make
women into sex slaves okay that would
actually be accurate as far as the evil
impulses of men but thankfully we have a
Western civilization that prevents men
from doing these things because men are
not all pigs contrary to feminist public
opinion again the idea that we just want
women to be baby machines I find
absolutely bizarre and I again I always
do this but I cite my own credentials
here is that I you know might we have
two kids my wife is a doctor and she
spends more time out of the house than I
do my mom worked my dad stayed at home
so this is not a society where I think
we all have to worry about becoming of
been right I just I don't think this is
that plus those costumes are so stupid
like it like really if again to go back
to my politically incorrect point if men
were to run a society where they use
women to sex slaves they would not
presumably dress them like
[Applause]
and but first of all thank you so much
for coming here honestly I need you here
and you to do certain stuff you said so
I appreciate the question I had for you
today was how do you think our
educational system can be reformed in
some sort of way to further promote
debate among vigilance okay so I mean
the higher education system where each
other okay so the biggest problem in the
higher education system right now is
that it's a self-perpetuating
aristocracy basically you have a bunch
of professors who have to determine who
their PhD students are if you are a left
professor in the chances that you're
going to admit a right-leaning PhD
student is a lot lower than your going
to admit a left-leaning hp's do my
answer to this is essentially the same
as it is in all of our areas of American
life conservatives need to start their
own universities and conservatives need
to start hiring people straight out of
high school if they're qualified because
I'm not I don't we have tremendous meat
I in the debate system that currently
exists in America's college campuses
having some significant experience with
different college campuses that are not
so good and so I think I think you can
we confirm gates professor and professor
I don't intend that every college
Madison say when I was in Harvard Law
School I really enjoy debating with my
professors
a number of professors were really fond
left and we try going back and forth
with it
I don't think all professors are seeking
to quash debate but we have to be wary
of the ones that are and the only way to
fix that is really to having a
competitor system of colleges or having
alumni be very much aware of the
professors on campus who are seeking to
quash debate and threaten to the cold
their money from campuses in which they
someone who understand think you're
familiar with South what you standard
mismatch theory
[Music]
it's why the dropout rate among black
students and top their couch is much
higher than their their students by the
racism because it is based on experts
that are being given on the basis it's
it's a tragedy because the fact is
especially with underground it also
wouldn't have gone to Harvard then are
possible if you see less of plenty good
school there were people from UT or in
my class and are possible as much as
where are you go to grad school and you
can have to earn your way in wherever
you go because then we know that you're
qualified for the position Mabel and you
yourself are going to be able to stand
up to the rigors in academic life there
are certain percentage of people will
define based on
which they didn't give it that's not
really the question the question is
whether you are
[Applause]
[Music]
so now my question is I grew up in Egypt
obviously I'm a Coptic Christian
suffered from persecution so I came here
five years ago and I realized that a lot
of people here are easily offended and
[Laughter]
and that they haven't even like been
through like burning down your churches
yes yeah and like a lot of
discrimination that I've faced and all
that and I understand there's a little
bit of discrimination maybe some racism
here in the United States but the left
makes it as if it's like really a huge
deal and it's like like Saudi Arabia or
something like that
so my question is why the especially the
younger generation here in the United
States are so easily offended and I'm
gonna say it's soft yeah I mean I think
that as I said in the speech I think
that because people have not been taught
what it means to be a good human being
and I think being a good human being
means essentially taking responsibility
for your actions at root it's it's much
easier to perceive yourself as a victim
it gives you an easy out things are bad
in your life well just blame somebody
else
you know the you're not succeeding
someone you know isn't succeeding it
must be due to some societal obstacle
now as I've said a thousand times and
I'll say a thousand more if you can show
me a specific instance of discrimination
happening then I'm perfectly happy to
stand next to you as everyone I'm sure
in this room is happy to stand next to
you and protest it but instead what we
get are broad generalizations about
racism and American life there's no way
to fight that and it's really just
virtue signaling because then as soon as
I say well you know I don't see evidence
of broad discrimination in American life
- you're ignorant
oh you don't want to look it in the face
you're not acknowledging your white
privilege and it's like well no I like
evidence from my propositions and if you
are going to suggest that all of America
is racist
then they need to answer your question
which is no like why where are you
seeing this misfortune that has been
attributed to victimhood and when you
take away somebody's victimhood they
feel as though you have attacked their
identity which is one of the reasons I
think that I get protested on campuses
because I say so often that if you're a
woman in America you're not a victim if
you're a black person in America you are
not inherently a victim if you're a Jew
in America you're not a victim if you're
LGBT that doesn't mean you're a victim
right you have to show me how you were
victimized and then we can talk about
whether you're a victim
but people's feelings are easily
offended when they have invested their
entire meaning in being a victim and as
I say you can you can invest your
identity in I'm a hard worker or I'm a
good person or I'm a person who tries to
fill what God wants of me or you can
invest your identity and I'm a victim of
society and however somebody threatens
your identity you're going to be you're
going to be upset and so if I threaten
your identity as a victim or you do are
saying you know you're not you're not a
victim then then you are gonna get in
hot water with all those people thank
you
okay mr. Shapiro I just wanted to start
off by saying that I'm very honored to
be here and see you in person I've
watched on YouTube like a lot thank you
I got an inspiration to me so with that
being said do you think that women who
voted for Hillary women who have
strongly supported the feminist movement
and supported the left are feeling
disenfranchised given the current
climate of sexual brutality and
oppression brought to light in Hollywood
recently so I think that people have a
willingness to blind themselves to facts
that they don't want to see and so what
I've seen a lot is people saying well
the problem of sexual harassment isn't
unique to Hollywood and has nothing to
do with our culture regarding sex a
leftist culture regarding sex no it has
to do generally with men right it has to
do generally with American society it
has to do generally with power
relationships it's funny how everybody
is willing to generalize as soon as
their ox is gored right as soon as as
soon as the left sees weight our culture
our feminist culture that we said that
we were gonna promulgate was gonna
protect women hasn't protected women you
know nearly at all then all of a sudden
it turns into well it's not us that's in
it's men that's in right and and so I've
been getting a lot of this online in the
last couple of days it's it's you men
who haven't stood up and I keep saying
like what do you want me to do and I'll
do it really what do you want me to do
like if you show me a rapist like Harvey
Weinstein allegedly is then I will say
send him to jail or castrate him right
like this is not difficult but if you
just say to me you don't acknowledge the
rape culture again I need you to define
that and I need you to explain to me
what I did I think really hey I knew
anything and I think the vast majority
of people in this room didn't do
anything and if they did do something
that maybe people should report it to
the police because that seems to me the
best way to root out evil is to actually
have law enforcement get involved so the
left is the question of what the left is
doing about this do they feel
disenfranchised no I think they're just
gonna blame the same people they always
blame because we're all in our own
little bubbles should they feel
disenfranchised 100% because in a
society that treats sex is transactional
in a society that basically reduces sex
to any sort just a physical transaction
that is based solely on consent it makes
it very difficult to explain why it is
that the casting couch in Hollywood is
bad per se right there's actually like a
feminist theory says that it's bad
because of power imbalances but the sort
of libertarian culture of left
suggests that power and balance doesn't
have anything to do with it if I feel
like trading my body for a part in a
movie well that's my business and if you
say differently than your slut-shaming
me right so that's it well you can't
really have it both ways either it's bad
or it's not bad and if we are going to
fight sexual harassment and sexual
assault it seems to me that we have to
do a couple of things one we have to
reinvest sex with value beyond just a
physical transaction it's not just two
people who are getting each other's
rocks off it actually means something
beyond that there's a relationship
that's attached to it and beyond that I
think that we need to re-encode Kate in
men themselves not just the teach men
not to rape routine like again it's such
a weird concept like when I was 11 my
dad didn't sit me down and say son don't
rape people like if you have to teach
your child that my guess is that you got
a bigger problem than that on your hands
what my dad taught me was to be a
gentleman and to treat women with
respect and that has to do with being a
gentleman and recognizing differences in
sex roles because one of the things
that's happened is the traditional
masculinity the idea that is a man's job
to protect women this is one of our jobs
as human beings as men to protect women
the feminist movement doesn't like that
well then you can't blame us for not
protecting women if you don't want us to
protect women like I want to protect
women I think men should protect women I
think one of the reasons God put man on
earth is to protect women ok well then
it is incumbent on me to protect women
but if you're telling me that I can't
even open a door for a woman because
this is somehow an offense to her honor
and then if I say that it's man's job to
protect women that this is somehow
reinforcing gender stereotypes then
don't come whining to me when bad stuff
happens because the answer to bad
behavior is good behavior the answer to
vice is virtue the answer device isn't
just yelling and hashtagging crap
hello my name is David Hamilton again
super happy here like everyone else um
my question is preggers University came
out with a video it was like why the
left or how the left is fundamentally
different than the right really great
video changed my perception on a lot of
things but one thing they talked about
was fundamentally the right act from the
inside out
and fundamentally the left act from the
outside in and so I guess engaging
people on the campus who are
fundamentally different than you how do
you go about doing that and then also
how do you go about doing that like with
politics some people who just
fundamentally don't see it the way that
you do well so I think that you have to
have a common language so you know for
example I'm a religious person I rarely
rarely scent religion in any argument
that I make I try to have a secular
rationale because I'm trying to speak a
language that I think more people speak
and then I think everyone is capable of
speaking you know I I think the first
thing that you have to do is you have to
remove a self-appointed sense of virtue
that so many people on the Left have I'm
a better person than you that's why I
started the speech tonight by suggesting
no you're not right all the people in
here believe the same things that you
believe about evil behavior now can we
get down to what we actually think
politics are about if you remove the
onion the unearned sense of moral
superiority to the left loves to engage
in then they actually have to get down
to business and this this does work I
mean I've done it routinely on
television if you ever watched me debate
anybody on the left it's actually my
first move always right which is to say
okay we're going to not insult each
other here now let's have a discussion
and half the time that ends the
discussion because there no more there
are no more arguments other than the
insults and if somebody is insulting you
I would say that you know the best thing
you can do is just walk away from the
conversation sometimes because it's not
worth wasting your time but I think that
you have to determine whether somebody
is worth engaging or not pretty much in
the first 30 seconds of a conversation a
lot of conversations are not necessarily
worth engaging
mr. Shapiro thank you for coming out
like everyone elseís said my question is
so you've had former libertarian
presidential candidate Austin Peterson
on your show few times and you've come
out in support of a lot of his ideas and
what he stands for and he is now running
in Missouri for Senate as a Republican
and his chances of getting elected of
skyrocketed just by putting an R next to
his name even though he's running with
the same policy positions etc so my
question is how do you feel about the
two-party system and a possible
conservative libertarian alliance so I
think a conservative libertarian merger
is the direction in which the Republican
Party is going to end up moving and what
I mean by this is I think the
conservatives have to understand that
libertarians are basically right about
government the government sucks at
everything and libertarians need to
understand that conservatives are right
that you do need social networks outside
of government of people helping each
other and promulgating common values
there's unfortunately in some parts of
the libertarian movement this sort of
antipathy toward churches and synagogues
that these are these are purveyors of
untruth right we are though whether
these are people who believe in the
spaghetti monster ooh right and I think
that and I think that a lot of
libertarians gonna have to get over that
crap because the fact is that without
the virtues that are instilled by
religion there cannot be a free society
right even Voltaire who is an atheist
recognized that he wanted his servant
and his wife to be religious people he
said they would steal from him cuckold
him less if they were so even atheist
libertarians should probably acknowledge
that one I do think that that merger is
is going to happen I think it's already
happening frankly but that's gonna be
the battle inside the Republican Party
is going to be basically whether there's
a conservative a conservative liberal
merger whether the the Republican Party
becomes a big government party that
basically just wants closed borders or
whether it's gonna be a party that is
that is more libertarian and orientation
hello mr. Shapiro I thank you so much
for coming out I'm a huge fan you're one
of the biggest role models for me I've
seen you so no thank you I appreciate my
question basically is as obviously a
black man how when I say I'm colorblind
I mean I'm like physically color sure
sure
and as a conservative who one does not
believe in my privilege I don't believe
that exists and as someone who believes
in individualism and does not believe
that he is a victim you know I'm
obviously have in my opinion the
greatest University but how do i
basically combat other primarily other
blacks who basically call me names you
know the classics you know all the time
oh that all that jazz and how do i
combat that and basically say explain to
them how they like me are not victims so
I mean I think that the first thing that
you have to do is something that you've
already talked about which is just you
have to say you're an individual I'm an
individual let's stop talking as black
people and let's start talking as
individuals now as an individual would
you like to succeed in life would you
like it and is what you should say right
you say do you want to succeed in life
because it because you're obviously
succeeding but there are a lot of people
who are not and one of the great
barriers to success is feeling that
you're a victim and feeling that society
is putting you behind the eight-ball how
about try my way for a year I try my way
for a year where you ignore these
societal obstacles that face you and you
just put your nose to the grindstone and
you work really hard and I promise you
there gonna be a lot of people out there
who are willing to help you and want to
help you and want to see you succeed and
no one has ever gotten ahead by by
complaining about the society itself the
way that you get ahead in America at
least in a free country right in an
oppressive country then maybe this helps
but in a free country then the only way
you get ahead is has an individual you
know if someone wants it first of all I
think that if someone tributes a name to
you like that the first thing that you
can say is that if Simone says you know
your Uncle Tom I think the first thing
we should say is well no you're an
so because because there's more evidence
that are an than that you're an
Uncle Tom and I mean that very seriously
the slurring people without evidence is
one of my least favorite games and if
somebody slurs you that way I'm not sure
you can honestly have a great
conversation with them anyway but I
think that when you treat people as
individuals there's a there's a certain
seductive nature to that because
everyone in the end wants to be treated
as more than their skin color I think
you're doing a great job of that right
now I think I'm probably talking to a
future senator from the state so so
thanks for coming thanks for asking the
question
hey Ben my name is Kiki I'm a huge fan
of yours um I'm not sure if you've know
three finnaly but I'm a huge sports fan
and recently I've knows how ESPN
becoming really left-wing and how
they're embracing late caught on yeah
yeah no big mystery right mouthing a
follow up question after this but I'm at
the NY ESPN briefing that left lane
politics into their audience okay so I
think that some of it is bubble think
and some of it I think is actual market
research that's driving them to the left
so so the the bubble think is pretty
simple most of the people in sports
media exist on the coast they exist in
New York or LA they exist in big media
markets those big media markets lean
left so the pool from which they're
drawing is a bunch of people who are
left the the sport the the market
research that I'm talking about and I
actually have done a pretty deep dive on
ESPN because I used to watch ESPN
incessantly I used to love ESPN I used
to be a subscriber to Sports Illustrated
I cancelled my subscription circle 2015
when they when every week it seemed they
were putting Caitlyn Jenner on the cover
someone who had not been athletically
relevant since before my birth and so at
that point I was like okay if I want to
read about transgenderism won't get
People magazine if I want to read about
sports please give me some news about a
sport involving involving balls
[Applause]
kind of win somewhere I wasn't expecting
but you know so the so I think so here's
here's what the market research says
that the market research says that ESPN
spent an outsized amount of time
focusing on the NBA they think that's
the real growth area is the NBA and if
you look at the the constituency of
people who watch the NBA it is it is
disproportionately black folks who watch
the NBA and are watching longer hours
pikal young black men are watching the
NBA in larger numbers those people tend
to be more politically to the left and
that means that ESPN is skewing to the
left in order to pick up some of those
viewers that at least would not be
illogical that at least make a certain
amount of sense I think is a big mistake
on their part because I think that
number one I love the NBA I love
watching the NBA but I don't want my NBA
in fuse of politics I think black folks
are just as likely to watch the NBA
whether it's infused with politics or
not when we all tuned in to ESPN I think
we all are wanting to watch the same
thing and I'm not really that concerned
about what LeBron James message is
putting on his sneakers on opening night
and I'm much more concerned with are
these people good at basketball so I
think it's a mistake by ESPN I think
they're losing subscribers
hand-over-fist and I think that they
should but I think that's probably the
combined reason behind the move to the
left
Jones so I do not know enough about this
issue to
are you doing been doing alright how are
you I'm doing pretty good so I know
you're coming I was struggling to think
of a question I watch a lot of your
stuff I wanted hear something that you
haven't said before and I saw your
parrot article about the thing was that
I Idaho oh yeah the Weekly Standard
article yeah and I know your advice to
students is keep your head down I wanted
to know your advice for professors right
lending professors and administrators
like should they keep their head down
until they got tenure yes I mean it
depends so that what do they want to be
employed or do they not want to be
employed unfortunately there's a
witch-hunt mentality that's occurring on
a lot of these campuses I wrote an
article my weekly standard that came out
today bad guy named Scott yin or who's a
political science and philosophy
professor over at Boise State and and
Scott wrote an article about
transgenderism that basically suggested
that transgenderism is an outgrowth of
the feminist movement this was posted on
the school website so they post
everything on the school website the
students went nuts the faculty tried to
throw them out
he has tenure so he'll survive but it
was basically a witch hunt and this sort
of witch hunt has taken place at
Evergreen State College with Brett
Weinstein
it's a place at Yale with the Christakis
ah's it's taking place at UCLA with with
one of the professors there so all over
the place I think that you're listen you
you lift your head up you're gonna risk
getting knocked down once you have
tenure I think that you're you're pretty
safe and it's very difficult to get rid
of you but there's a reason that
academia is so far the left and a lot of
it is this this enforced censorship
hi Ben hey there's actually funny three
nights ago watching this video if you
destroy Piers Morgan and I was like wow
I really want them to come here and I
found out too that you're here so that's
what so first I'd like to say that it
seems like the abortion argument only
became a woman's right issue after the
argument from science failed for them
I'm only 21 but it seems to me like the
argument from when I remember it started
off as being science-based with like a
human at conception it's just a zygote
like a zygote of a monkey a fish at
often whatever and I remember like
seeing images in middle school of them
showing like the early development and
showing how like oh there's no
difference here so but then through like
research embryology we find out like the
DNA genetic template is they're human
like what you're gonna be it's there
from the beginning it says it all
so to my question in a society today
where a specifically women have been so
successfully convinced that an abortion
isn't to be frowned upon how can we
convince young women to not get
abortions when the voice of abortions
aren't bad seems to be louder than the
voice of like personal responsibility
and like basic morality so I mean I
think that the first thing is that again
people blind themselves to two answers
they don't want to see and it's our job
to break through that so I've spoken
about this I hate euphemisms with regard
to abortion abortion is filled with us
um is immense right to choose it's just
terminating a pregnancy no you are
killing a human life in the womb and we
should describe in graphic detail
exactly what happens when that happens
okay when you're talking about a middle
to late stage fetus that is developed
you're talking about in many cases the
actual dismemberment of a human being in
the womb you're talking about crushing
skulls and sucking brains into sinks you
are talking about torturing a child in
the womb and then killing it and that
has to be that has to be brought out
because people need to feel the
gut-wrenching nature of what it is that
is being conducted they also need to be
shown as many pictures as possible what
a fee of what a baby looks like in the
womb
because there is still a in you know you
can make the intellectual argument for
for an embryo having the same moral
value as seven month old fetus and I
think that that's a pretty good argument
actually but I think that the
emotional argument is seeing a picture
of the seven month old fetus and when
you see when you know that you can tell
the sex of your baby at 10 weeks which
you can then it's very difficult to
argue that this is not an independent
human being with an independent with an
independent DNA with independent blood
type then the more scientific knowledge
that we put out there the worse it gets
for the left and this is why this is one
of the few issues where the right is
actually moving in the right direction
in terms of the polls if you look at the
abortion statistics and and how many
people actually believe in the
pro-choice position it's been declining
steadily over the last 15 years and it's
gonna get a lot worse because the better
we can see into the womb the more
difficult it is for the pro-choice left
to suggest that this is not a human life
it's just a cluster of cells Thanks
hi mr. Shapiro it's wonderful to meet a
fellow sabbath-keeping Nazis so as where
as we are we were rare birds so I have
actually I want to go over a quote with
you from Milton Freeman and just get
your thoughts on it this is from I think
it's capitalism and freedom a society
that puts equality before freedom will
end up with neither the society that
puts freedom before equality will end up
with a great measure of both underlying
most arguments against the free market
is a lack of belief in freedom itself
and I just wanted to kind of get your
thoughts on that particular I mean of
course I think that's true I think that
free markets are based on the idea that
you are in charge of your own labor
right we all inherently understand this
that what was wrong with slavery what
was wrong with slavery is that we were
we were taking human beings and telling
them that they were nothing but pack
beasts and treating them as such we were
depriving them their time we were
depriving their labor without
compensation we were treating them the
way that we wanted to treat them without
regard to their wishes your labor what
you do with your life is what freedom
constitutes and so when we say that in
the name of equality we have to limit
that freedom in the name of
redistribution we have to take away some
of your freedom then that is an
imposition on me as a human being that
is an imposition on what I am John Locke
famously suggested that private property
exists because you mix your labor with
land right you mix your labor with
property it is your labor that is one of
the only things that you as a human
being owned inherently is what you can
do with your time and with your body
basically and two for the government to
step in and so funny the left will
acknowledge this with regards to matters
on sex but they have no idea they will
not acknowledge it with regards to any
sort of matter with regard to labor but
if I'm in a consensual relationship with
somebody at a job meaning like they are
paying me a wage and I'm working for
that wage and I'm receiving that way
they think it's incumbent on them to
step in and stop it
but if I'm in a consensual sexual
relationship then it is incumbent on me
to get out of the way according to the
left I have a feeling that it's
incumbent time you go out of the way in
both cases so so freedom I really is is
the underlying methodology it's one of
the reasons why I've said a thousand
times people have always said this
stupid line on the right that socialism
is a great idea in prayer in in theory
just doesn't work in practice
no it's an evil idea in theory and it
doesn't work in practice it's an evil
idea because it suggests that your
belongs to me that by dint of birth I
have a right to deprive you of that
which is yours and that is not correct
that is not morally correct it is not
fiscally correct that is not
economically correct freedom is is what
undergirds your vet freedom is an
acknowledgment that you are an
independent human being with independent
human value and I have no right to
impinge on that value
hello mr. Shapiro my name is Wesley Reed
and throughout like I've been paying
attention to politics more recently and
that's swated me to actually change my
major to political science and you hear
all the time like racial inequality and
this kind of thing and like how they're
pushing this is issues and stuff
when I like I like to look at it as a
like sort of the idea of economic
inequality how like rural America and
like inner cities and this kind of
things get more like they get I guess I
don't know how to really say it but
they're neglected more than like races
of people and I just wanna get your
thoughts on the idea of economic
inequality and like how we can go about
fixing that ok so I do not tend to worry
about economic inequality in the sense
that I don't think that every economic
inequality is necessarily economic
inequity so inequality means that we
have the same amount of money equity
means that it's fair that we have the
same amount of money I don't think these
are the same thing at all so if you show
me you know an impoverished area the
first thing I have to ask is is it
unjust that this area is is impoverished
and this may seem like a harsh question
but that takes into account a number of
factors other than just the
impoverishment of the area right if I go
out tomorrow and I take all of my money
and I spend on lottery tickets and then
I blow it all on lottery tickets then I
am poor again that is not unjust that is
the natural consequence of my
decision-making so you have to determine
in every case whether the inequality is
inequity and then there's a second sort
of question which is if it is an
inequity is it a curable inequity is it
something where we can step in and
actually fix it because the inequity has
been performed by someone on someone
else there are inequities in life that
happened just because life is unfair
right people fall they get hurt people
get sick people get cancer is that
something that is my fault does that
give you the right to take away from me
is that inequity or is that just
something tragic that happens so there
are several categories here so when we
talk about impoverishment in rural areas
in Appalachia or in the inner-city and
then we have to determine okay why is
the impoverishment happening is the
impoverishment happening because for
example there's an opioid epidemic and
too many people are taking part in it or
is it happening because there's a drug
culture or is it happening because
single motherhood has created a culture
of intergenerational poverty or is it
happening because people are not
cultivating proper
skills and assuming that the factory
that was there for dad is gonna be there
for me and the factory is not going to
be there no matter how many times Donald
Trump says it's coming back and he just
punishes China right is we have to
actually like we actually have to
determine what is the inequity that we
can solve here or is the best solution
you making individual good decisions and
me getting everyone else out of the way
and in 95% of situations the answer is
the is that right is that fairness in
life you know lack of cosmic justice is
tamas so a-- puts it is not curable by
the collective coming in and stamping on
somebody else's rights it is only
curable by you making different
decisions or working harder and again
that doesn't mean life is fair but it
does mean that the that the rules are
fair right because there there's two
types of fairness right there the in in
sports the referee judges everybody the
same or one team is worse and so the
referee gives them points the the second
way is not fair
it's not fair to the other team
they've been things coming so my
question is on a gun control so we've
all heard what all knowing Jimmy Kimmel
thinks I've gone control but yeah our
great moral Savior yeah yeah yeah yeah
but we're not bouncing women on
trampolines I'll just like to hear it so
if like you were present what policies
do you see like put in place cuz I know
you're for further background checks for
criminal history and mental illness and
mental illness yes so so there's there
are significant holes in the system
whereby somebody has been has actually
you know been to mental hospital for
mental illness and then they still have
access to a gun this seems to me foolish
and the the biggest problem here
honestly is that the government is again
really bad in enforcing things so in the
state of California there are like
thirty thousand people who had guns and
who are on the mental illness list and
the state knew about them and they had
30 people to police those thirty
thousand people and trying to remove
guns from them good luck with that so
well I think the background checks for
mental illness need to be strengthened
and made more transparent I think that
well that would be the the chief
criticism as far as some of the other
background checks I mean universal
background checks essentially exist now
except with regard to hand-to-hand
purchases which is not a gun show
loophole it's just a hand hand purchase
loophole and it's gonna be almost
impossible to police that anyway because
if I decide to sell you my gun unless
you got in commit a crime nobody's ever
gonna know about it for the rest of
human history so that's that's very
difficult to police beforehand I think
that what I had said is that when it
came to Las Vegas the obvious one is is
there's a case to be made for regulation
of bump stocks because it turns a
semi-auto into an effective automatic
weapon but the big problem there again
is you can you can do that I'm not sure
it's gonna be super effective because
you can manufacture a bump stock with
basically a spring so it's not it's not
super difficult and you can also bump
fire a rifle if you know what you're
doing so it's so my answer on gun
control generally is that the problem is
not the presence of guns in a given
society the problem is the presence of
bad people in a given society or the
presence of mentally ill people in a
given society who should not be at
liberty for example
that that is the bigger problem to me I
mean if you look at the states in the
Union there's there's no correlation in
the states in the Union between level of
gun ownership and level of crime in fact
virtually all crime in the United States
exists in major cities right which tend
to vote blue right and where there is
heavy gun control out in rural America
is not where people are shooting each
other up it's it's happening almost
entirely in in blue counties in red
states for example right people say Oh
Louisiana really high gun crime rate
right it's all in New Orleans right
that's it really I mean if you look if
you look at where it's located it's all
in New Orleans so that that's worthy of
note
hey then howdy
let's see I'm the leader of a political
Club on a small Christian college mean
some of my members drove up here today
to see you and so I wanted to ask you a
question that's relevant for us on our
campus what I've noticed talking the
students on campus are our two trends
either a very socialistic idea of
Christianity and religion where God
wants us to share God wants us to
basically not have private property
because private property includes greed
in all these vices and then the idea
that this world is not our home and so
we shouldn't care about what happens on
the earth politically right how would I
go forth bringing issues to their mind
and getting them to care about these
issues without calling into question
their religion okay so I am NOT going to
play a Christian theologian I'm not
really qualified for that I will say
however that there is a very solid case
to be made that Matthew's admonition
that if you're not going to work you're
not going to eat
applies across the board and also the
idea that the idea that this world is of
no consequence whatsoever has not been
held true in in very many Christian
societies that I can imagine the there
have been you know communistic Christian
essentially small groups since inception
I mean really since the time of Christ
but they have not tended to work out
particularly well when it talks in in in
the Gospels about the idea that they
they were a family and they shared among
them basically and they shared all was
common two of them that is a specific
that's a specific claim for a specific
time and not only that for a specific
group of people so the way that I always
put it is that the purpose of
Christianity at least with with the with
the disciples of Jesus was to create a
family right and Jesus is very clear
about this right Jesus is constantly
saying things like you put your put your
father and mother as I do it right this
is this is the new family essentially
well in your family you're a socialist
right you are like in my family I'm a
socialist ma'am my wife and I share a
bank account I make a lot more money my
wife she and I share a bank account when
my child lives off the excess of my
labor right
both of them do particularly the girl
but she's three-and-a-half but the but
but that is not broaden tubal to all of
civilization simply because it doesn't
work that way and every time you have a
society that attempts to impose this it
fails the the most obvious example
actually of a Christian Christian group
trying this were the Puritans when they
first arrived in the United States the
Pilgrims and they first arrived in the
United States when the pilgrims first
arrived in the United States the actual
story of Thanksgiving goes something
like this they arrived in the United
States they decide to set up a commune
okay the original pilgrim setting was a
communist opted working okay and then
Squanto who was a convert to
Christianity showed up and he said okay
guys we're gonna need to actually do
some farming now and then they did some
farming and then William Bradford who
was the governor of the colony said
we're gonna get rid of all of this and
we're gonna have private property and
now we're gonna own our own plots of
land and everything was hunky-dory
so from an effectiveness point of view
it's doesn't hold true also the idea
that you're supposed to just abandon
politics in this life completely would
suggest that maybe they should leave me
alone more than anything else right I
mean if they want to abandon politics in
this life then going after my bank
account doesn't seem like a real proper
way of doing it
hey Ben I appreciate you coming today my
question is in regards to your
philosophy in the in your Aristotelian
conception of reason is reason to buy
and divide arrive from an innate sense
of self or rather discernment within the
biblical context so it is it is derived
from I think they are incontinence with
one another so I'm a more of a follower
of Maimonides and Aquinas on this I
don't think those two things are in
conflict so the innate sense of self is
a divine gift in other words you can
investigate your own reason and that is
something that comes from a divine place
it comes from in the Aristotelian sense
it from the unmoved mover who implanted
a implanted that in us so that we could
fulfill our Telos you know that's that's
more individuals individualistic sense
of Aristotle then probably Aristotle
would would appreciate but that's that's
sort of the Aquinas read on Aristotle
and it's the reason by the way why
Aristotle came back to light the reason
that Aristotle came back to light after
centuries of non study is after his
rediscovery in both East and West in the
12th century
he was basically popularized by
Maimonides in in the Jewish community
and their Islamic scholars who
popularized Aristotle and Aquinas
popularized Aristotle and it was that it
was the mashup of judeo-christianity
with Aristotelian logic that creates the
modern world is my contention
essentially thanks
great well thank you so much for coming
out I really appreciate it good to see
all of it